anti-abortion activists are turning
their attention to Louisiana which could
be the next state to impose tighter
restrictions on abortion rights the
pending State House vote comes as
legislators in Missouri overwhelmingly
passed a sweeping law Friday placing new
restrictions on doctors who perform
abortions the law bans the procedure
after eight weeks of pregnancy with no
exceptions for rape or incest doctors
could face up to 15 years in prison for
performing an abortion Kenneth Craig is
here with the latest Kenneth good
morning good morning to you Dana the
Missouri law is the latest victory for
the anti-abortion movement and it comes
in the same week that Alabama passed its
own law restricting abortions
oh you're voting 109 yes before tea no
you approve the peasy move the previous
question the vote on House bill 126
restricting abortions in the state of
Missouri wasn't close but it came after
a fiery debate on the House floor I'm
here to tell you that our freedom cannot
be bought with the blood of our children
we are seizing her we may as well be the
ones tying her hands to the bedposts and
forcing her into childbirth HB 126 bans
abortions after a fetal heartbeat can be
detected around eight weeks I will sign
the bill as it presented to me the bill
Republican Governor Mike parson intends
to sign does not include an exception
for pregnancies that result from rape or
incest this gives more rights to the
rapist than it does to the mother I've
never really studied but I've heard of
the morning-after pill where if someone
feels that they'd been sexually
assaulted they could go do that the vote
comes just one day after Alabama's
governor kiv signed into law a similar
bill that makes it a felony for a doctor
to perform nearly all abortions with the
exception of when a mother's health is
at serious risk the legality of both the
Alabama and Missouri laws could
ultimately be determined by the US
Supreme Court which ruled in 1973's roe
v wade that women have a constitutional
right to end a pregnancy I don't know
that we're gonna change anybody's
opinion right now on anything on that
particular issue on Thursday dr. David
Eisenberg medical director of the only
Planned Parenthood left in the state of
Missouri told CBS News the
does not settle the issue it doesn't
make abortion go away it just makes
abortion more difficult to access and
potentially more dangerous Missouri is
the fifth state to pass a so-called
heartbeat bill just this year
conservative states appear to be
emboldened by the Supreme Court's 5-4
conservative majority ever since justice
Brett Kavanaugh joined the court at the
end of last year Anthony thanks a lot
Kenneth